the epidemic is picking up speed
according to the latest data
the government office for science says
the r value which measures the rate the
virus is spreading
is now between 1.1 and 1.2 up on last
week
other figures revealed the rapid surge
in the virus as soon as lockdown was
lifted
the office for national statistics
estimates in the week up to the 12th of
december
more than 567 000 people in england had
the infection
again up sharply on the week before but
rates are rising
faster south of a line between bristol
and norwich
london and the east midlands have the
highest rates
with 1.4 percent of people infected
that's a rise of
40 percent in just a week in the east of
england they're up 67 percent
but in the northwestern yorkshire the
hot spots before lockdown
rates are falling it's pressure on the
nhs that has driven government policy
and nationally it soared in the spring
leading to lockdown
but new data lets us look at individual
hospital trusts and it shows just how
regional the uk's epidemic has been
this is imperial college healthcare a
big central london group of hospitals
see the sharp peak in covert emissions
back in the spring
and only a small rise this autumn
instead the virus had shifted north
this is the royal liverpool admissions
rose sharply in early october
putting the city into tier three that
brought serious illnesses under control
and restrictions were eased now the
virus is affecting the southeast take a
look at east kent
nhs trust where admissions started to
rise in september with only a brief
leveling off during lockdown
before continuing the surge they're now
well above levels in the first wave
across england more than fifteen
thousand people are currently in
hospital
but the british medical journal predicts
that could reach 19
000 by the end of december so what does
all this mean well the high infection
rates revealed by the ons
data combined with a household mixing
over christmas
is sure to lead to an explosive surge
first in cases then in hospital
admissions in january
it certainly won't be a happy new year
for the nhs
you